pour le romney alors qu'est-ce qui t'amène ici je
veux changer et j'ai entendu dire que tu pouvais
m'aider à
dire le mot simple frère
[Musique]
j'ai l'impression d'avoir ce trou que
j'ai essayé de combler
est-ce que tu pries cinq fois par jour il est
branler cinq fois par jour
j'ai essayé de le remplir de sexe mais ça
ne fait qu'empirer les choses
je veux que tu sois mon professeur je veux
tuer mon ego
comment puis-je savoir que je ne suis pas juste un autre
de tes désirs que je fais  Je ne veux pas avoir de relations sexuelles
avec toi,
bienvenue dans le passé, frère, nous
parlons toujours d'être musulman, ce
qui signifie que nous devons aider les autres à
baiser, c'est mal avec toi,
ton bouclier est
une discipline vraiment chaude.
veulent plus un homme comme moi
ils veulent un homme comme toi un homme qui se sent
un peu comme une femme mais qui est toujours
officiellement un homme
je sais que je peux être meilleur tu regardes
tout comme une bénédiction dans notre
malédiction la
vérité est que tout est à la fois  nous sommes
nés pour toujours
par amour compassion honnêteté
je dois savoir avoir  tu t'es douché depuis la
dernière fois que tu t'es masturbé
oh mec avec le il doit venir à allah
propre
euh euh
tout ce qui est bon est musulman c'est euh
c'est musulman
c'est un doux s comme euh chatte
chatte musulmane ouais chatte musulmane je pense
qu'il y a d'autres façons d'apprendre ça bien que
toi